[Music]
welcome to my latest experiment this is
the big one the one i've been waiting
for all my life
ah well it's a delorean right stay with
me marty all your questions will be
answered roll tape
time travel oof already getting a
headache thinking about it while the
science behind the phenomenon doesn't
exist there are plenty of wonderful
movies centered around it which is why
we are going to take a look at the best
time travel movies ever some movies
might get into the nitty nitty-gritty of
time travel going deep into the science
and make it seem plausible others have
fun with it getting us engaged with the
characters and story without worrying
whether or not the time travel aspect
actually makes sense whether it's taken
seriously or simply a fun ride we love a
good time travel movie
do you see yourself as a tourist or a
participant
i've excelled in advanced physics
biology and astronomy a tourist is
someone who travels across the ocean
only to be photographed standing next to
their boat
i have no intention of being a tourist
oh we're also including movies that deal
with time loops so pretty much anything
that messes with time we got you covered
so let's take a look at the past present
and the future as we count down the best
time travel movies all ranked by tomato
meter
[Music]
number 10 12 monkeys
traveling back in time isn't simple as
james cole learns the hard way
imprisoned in the 2030s james is
recruited for a mission that will send
him back to the 1990s once there he's
supposed to gather information about a
nascent plague that's about to
exterminate the vast majority of the
world's population but aside from the
manic geoffrey he gets little in the way
of cooperation not least from medical
gatekeepers like dr catherine raley
starring bruce willis madeleine stowe
brad pitt and directed by terry gilliam
critics say the plot's a bit of a jumble
but excellent performances and
mind-blowing plot twists make 12 monkeys
a kooky effective experience
[Music]
no mistakes this time cold
stay alert keep your eyes open i'm
thinking about the spider cole try to do
something like that again
just relax now don't fight it
we're sending you to the third quarter
of 1996 right on the money
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number nine safety not guaranteed a
disaffected magazine intern turn
befriends an unusual guy who is looking
for a partner to accompany him on a trip
back through time starring aubry plaza
mark duplass jake johnson and directed
by colin trevorrow critics say safety
not guaranteed ostensibly modest
ambition are outmatched by the movie's
strong performances beguiling charm and
heartfelt story
you should try cnr guns in wilkins
state of washington does not allow sale
of firearms and the business premises of
a grocer
what about those thingies
with the spiky
ball the end of the chain
things you know
you have those what exactly is the
intended use
is there a pest problem or
hunting well if your ad had been written
properly i may have a better idea of
what i need
my ad yeah
it's pretty sloppy excuse me you heard
me
i hope you worked harder on your
calibrations
my calibrations are flipping pinpoint
okay
there are people after me how do i know
you don't work for them because i've
never worked for anybody in my life you
ever face certain death if it was so
certain
i wouldn't be here would i
number eight edge of tomorrow
when earth falls under attack from
invincible aliens no military unit in
the world is able to beat them major
william cage an officer who has never
seen combat is assigned to a suicide
mission killed within moments cage finds
himself thrown into a time loop in which
he relives the same brutal fight and his
death over and over again however cage's
fighting skills improve with each encore
bringing him and a comrade ever closer
to defeating the aliens starring tom
cruise emily blunt brendan gleason and
directed by doug lyman critics say
gripping well-acted funny and clever
edge of tomorrow offers entertaining
proof that tom cruise is still more than
capable of shouldering the way of a
blockbuster action thriller
i'm sorry i'm trying to save you we're
getting slaughtered you need to get us
off this beach
we have to go this drop ship is about to
explode we have to go now
wait
come on
come on
come on
the ship is going to explode
what are you doing
find me when you wake up
come find me when you wake up
number seven source code helicopter
pilot coulter stevens is part of a top
secret military operation that enables
him to experience the last few minutes
in the life of sean fentress a man who
died in a commuter train explosion the
purpose of coulter's mission is to learn
the identity of the bomber and prevent a
similar catastrophe as coulter lives
sean's final moments he becomes more
certain that he can prevent the first
tragedy from occurring as long as he
doesn't run out of time starring jake
gyllenhaal michelle monahan vera farmiga
and directed by duncan jones critics say
finding the human story amidst the
action director duncan jones and a
charming jake gyllenhaal craft a smart
satisfying sci-fi thriller in source
code
ladies gentlemen transit security
classified security breach i need all of
you to turn off any personal electronic
devices till we pull into the station
okay that means laptops cell phones cell
phones sir cell phone sir thank you very
much pagers anything electronic thank
you it's just a precautionary measure
nothing to worry about so which is it
security breach or precautionary measure
sir
sir
is there a problem here sir
i'm in the middle of a very big deal
sean i need you to turn that off why
don't you show me that id again sean
turn it off turn it off what's your
problem
sean what are you doing
it's not a good idea man not a good idea
that's not a good idea i think you broke
his jaw it's okay he's not any more real
than you are i'm not real come on next
time you drive to work
number six looper
in a future society time travel exists
but it's only available to those with
the means to pay for it on the black
market when the mob wants to eliminate
someone it sends the target into the
past where hitman known as a looper
waits to finish the job joe is one such
hired gun and he does his job well until
the day his bosses decide to close the
loop and send joe's future self back in
time to be killed starring bruce willis
joseph gordon-levitt emily blunt and
directed by ryan johnson critics say as
thought-provoking as it is thrilling
looper delivers an uncommonly smart
bravely original blend of futuristic
sci-fi and good old-fashioned action
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
number five avengers end game a drift in
space with no food or water tony stark
sends a message to pepper potts as his
oxygen supply starts to dwindle
meanwhile the remaining avengers must
figure out a way to bring back their
vanquished allies for an epic showdown
with thanos the evil demigod who
decimated the planet and the universe
starring robert downey jr chris evans
scarlett johansson and directed by
anthony and joe russo critics say
exciting entertaining and emotionally
impactful avengers endgame does whatever
it takes to deliver a satisfying finale
to marvel's epic infinity saga you heard
the man stroke those keys jolly green
attractants engaged
you promised to bring that back in one
piece right yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay do my best
this promise is good that was pretty
lame
see in a minute
[Music]
number four palm springs
stuck in a time loop two wedding guests
develop a budding romance while living
the same day over and over again
starring andy samberg kristin miliotti
jk simmons and directed by max barbacow
critics say strong performances assure
direction and a refreshingly original
concept make palm springs a rom-com
that's easy to fall in love with
you're a sick [ __ ] roy
niles
miles oh stop don't come in here are you
okay don't come in here
hello
the [ __ ]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
number three back to the future
small town california teen marty mcfly
is thrown back into the 50s when an
experiment by his eccentric scientist
friend doc brown goes awry traveling
through time in a modified delorean
marty encounters young versions of his
parents and must make sure that they
fall in love or he'll cease to exist
even more dawningly marty has to return
to his own time and save the life of doc
brown starring michael j fox christopher
lloyd leah thompson and directed by
robert zemeckis critics say inventive
funny and breathlessly constructed back
to the future is a rousing time travel
adventure with an unforgettable spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see if you
can do 90.
[Music]
ah
number two groundhog day
weatherman phil is out to cover the
annual emergence of the groundhog from
its hole he gets caught in a blizzard
that he didn't predict and finds himself
trapped in a time warp he's doomed to
relive the same day over and over again
until he gets it right starring bill
murray andy mcdowell chris elliott and
directed by harold ramis critics say
smart sweet and inventive groundhog day
highlights murray's dramatic gifts while
still leaving plenty of room for laughs
did you sleep well mr connors
did i sleep well would you like some
coffee
yes please but i think i'll have a
double
i hope you enjoy the festivities
there's talk of a blizzard
do you ever have deja vu mrs lancaster
i don't think so but i could check with
the kitchen
no that's okay thank you
will you be checking out today mr
connors
i'd say the chance of departure is 80
percent
75.80
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
donnie darko
in a funny moving and distinctly
mind-bending journey through suburban
america one extraordinary but
disenchanted teenager is about to take
time's arrow for a ride after surviving
a freak accident donnie begins to
explore what it means to be alive and in
love he soon uncovers secrets of the
universe that give him a tempting power
to alter time and destiny starring jake
gyllenhaal jenna malone patrick swayze
and directed by richard kelly critics
say richard kelly's debut feature donnie
darko is a daring original vision packed
with jarring ideas and intelligence and
featuring a remarkable performance from
jake gyllenhaal as the troubled title
character mr darko
ling ling finds a wallet on the ground
filled with money she takes the wallet
to the address on the driver's license
but keeps the money inside the wallet
i'm i'm sorry mr i don't get this
just place an x on the lifeline in the
appropriate place
no i mean i know what to do i just i
don't get this you can't just lump
things into two categories things aren't
that simple the lifeline
is divided that way
well life isn't that simple
i mean who cares if lingling returns the
wallet and keeps the money has nothing
to do with either fear or love fear and
love are the deepest of human emotions
okay
but you're not listening to me
there are other things that need to be
taken into account here like
the whole spectrum of human emotion you
can't just
lump everything into these two
categories and then just deny everything
else
predestination
a temporal agent embarks on a final time
traveling assignment to prevent an
elusive criminal from launching an
attack that kills thousands of people
starring ethan hawk sarah snook noah
taylor and directed by michael and peter
spirig critics say fun genre fair with
uncommon intelligence predestination
serves as a better than average sci-fi
adventure and offers a star-making turn
from sarah snook
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'm so sorry
are you lost
no i'm looking for someone
thanks i'll just wait well you know what
they say about good things happening to
those who wait
but only the things left behind by those
who hustle
i was thinking the exact same thing
what are the odds
where are the odds
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
primer
[Music]
intellectual engineers aaron and abe
build and sell error checking technology
with the help of their friends robert
and phillip but when aaron and abe
accidentally invent what they think is a
time machine a build diversion capable
of transporting a human and puts the
device to the test as the two friends
obsess over their creation they discover
the dark consequences of their actions
starring david sullivan casey goodin and
shane carruth who also directed the film
critics say dense obtuse but stimulating
primer is a film for viewers ready for a
cerebral challenge
here's what's going to happen
i'm going to read this
and you're going to listen you're going
to stay on the line and you're not going
to interrupt you're going to speak for
any reason
some of this you know
i'm going to start at the top of the
page
meticulous
yes
methodical educated they were these
things
nothing extreme like anyone they varied
there were days of mistakes laziness and
infighting
and there were days
good days when by anyone's judgment they
would have to be considered clever
no one would say that what they were
doing was complicated
it wouldn't even be considered new
except for maybe in the geological sense
they took from their surroundings what
was needed
and made of it something more
and finally number one the terminator
disguised as a human a cyborg assassin
known as a terminator travels from 2029
to 1984 to kill sarah connor sent to
protect sarah is kyle reese who divulges
the coming of skynet an artificial
intelligence system that will spark a
nuclear holocaust sarah is targeted
because skynet knows that her unborn son
will lead the fight against them with
the virtually unstoppable terminator in
hot pursuit she and kyle attempt to
escape starring arnold schwarzenegger
linda hamilton michael bean and directed
by james cameron critics say with its
impressive action sequences taught
economic direction and relentlessly fast
pace it's clear why the terminator
continues to be an influence on sci-fi
and action flicks
[Music]
so
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you